Otaku Hero
What's going on?
Transformation, you can go after you've
transformed
When you start repaying what you just did
[applause] Even
black holes can't be blocked Such an attack won't work Because of the
setting, it can't be destroyed by something that belongs to the earth
What the hell is that setting
?  In the phantom theatrical version that ended, I
was supposed to show off the decisive move,
but this is the
phantom theatrical version No matter what, the Hydro League
Tornado Attack
[music] [
applause]
[music]
What is this?  It's the heart of justice that puts the absurdity right and
builds a bridge that leads to the future.